Electricity powers our world.
And we harness it through electrical engineering,
the field that focuses on the application of electricity
and electromagnetism in our everyday lives.
Just as you have blood pumping through your
veins, machines and systems often need electrical
power flowing through their wires to work.
It’s the lifeblood of our society.
And it’s hard to imagine society today without three
of the main branches of electrical engineering:
telecommunications, power and lighting;
and computer engineering.
They each came about in their own way, with
their own challenges and victories, their own
heroes and sometimes villains.
And you’d be surprised how much death is
involved in the history of electrical engineering.
Well, it can be dangerous.
[Theme Music]
Electrical engineering deals with the properties
of electricity and magnetism.
So it stands to reason that the field didn’t really
exist until we knew what those things were.
No one had a very good understanding of electromagnetism
until English physicist William Gilbert released
his principal work, De Magnete, or “On the Magnet”,
back in 1600.
After years of experimentation, he found that the needle
of a compass points north-south and dips downwards
because the Earth is basically a giant magnet.
He was the first to describe the phenomena we now
associate with electrical attraction and magnetic poles,
which is why many view him as
the father of electrical studies.
Now, electrical conduction – which is the movement
of electrically charged particles through a transmission
medium –
wasn’t discovered until around 1729, by a
British scientist – Stephen Gray.
He discovered it while doing experiments in which
he connected a glass tube to various objects, like an
ivory ball or a piece of cork, by wire or string.
When he rubbed the glass tube, creating friction,
he found the object at the other end of the line
would be electrified.
With the age of discovery and colonization upon
the world, could Gray’s work be used to produce
a faster means of communication?
This brings us to the start of the first field
of electrical engineering: telecommunication.
Efforts to communicate over long distances,
by things like semaphore, were undertaken as
early as the 1700s.
But it wasn’t until 1837 that Sir William
Fothergill Cooke and Charles Wheatstone
patented the first electric telegraph.
Their design used five or six magnetic needles
to sway right or left to indicate specific letters.
This early model was a little impractical
because of its cost, but the men later patented a
new version that only used one magnetic needle.
Their invention was clearly a neat idea.
But it didn’t really take off, until it was used to
solve a murder that sounds like it was lifted from
the pages of a Sherlock Holmes novel.
On New Year’s Day 1845, a man named John Tawell
gave a woman he was seeing a fatal dose of poison.
As the poison set in, she started to scream,
which alerted the neighbors.
And Tawell ran off in a panic, thinking he
escaped the law as he boarded a train from
Slough to London.
But his escape was foiled by technology.
His description was sent by telegraph to London,
where Tawell was arrested and later tried and hanged.
It’s a rather gruesome way to make an
invention popular, but it spread the story of
the electric telegraph nonetheless.
Around the same time as all of this was happening,
Samuel Morse was making his own developments
in the United States.
He figured out how to use an electromagnet
with a pen, so that when the electromagnet was
energized, the pen made a mark on paper.
In 1838, he developed a system of dots and
dashes, now known as Morse code, so that
messages could be easily transmitted.
By 1844, he had obtained financial support
from Congress and built the first telegraph
line in the United States.
It travelled between Baltimore and Washington,
and on May 24th, he sent the line’s first message,
“What hath God wrought.”
Pretty ominous, if I do say so myself.
About 20 years later, in 1866, the British ship
Great Eastern succeeded in laying the first permanent
telegraph line across the Atlantic Ocean.
Before it, large bodies of water were a big
obstacle for means of telecommunication.
After the transatlantic telegraph line, some engineers
began to realize that by fluctuating an electric current,
they could induce different sound vibrations.
It made them wonder, if they could
manipulate sound vibrations,
could they input a sound on one end of a telegraph
line and replicate the same sound on the other end?
Could they capture the human voice?
By 1876, they did just that, with the invention
of the telephone.
A few different minds came up with similar ideas
at the same time, but Alexander Graham Bell was
the first to get the patent.
He was able to use a fluctuating current to vary the magnetism in the coil of an electromagnet, which caused a small piece of iron to vibrate on a diaphragm.
This replicated the vibration that had initially sent
the fluctuation, which reproduced the initial sound.
Now you could call talk to people who were
far away, but you still needed telephone lines and
a phone with a physical connection to them.
But that changed when Heinrich Hertz discovered
electromagnetic waves around 1887.
It was soon realized that these waves could
carry a signal by modifying their wavelength,
amplitude, and frequency.
This led to the radio, and the never-ending
confusion over who gets credit for inventing it.
Now, after World War I, electrical engineers
manipulated these signals and found that along with
the conversion of light to electrical impulses,
they could create a visual broadcast: television.
Since then, we’ve taken these signals even
further.
With the internet and wifi, we’ve developed
nearly instant, wireless communication around
the world.
But electrical engineering is far more than
telecommunication.
We have electrical engineering to thank for
supplying power and light.
In 1801, Sir Humphry Davy discovered that he
could produce a brilliant spark, or arc, between
two carbon rods in a battery circuit.
This is called arc lighting.
Davy’s battery wasn’t powerful enough
to produce a stable arc.
So arc lighting wasn’t commercially
feasible until the 1870’s,
after Belgian-born engineer Zénobe-Théophile
Gramme developed a generator that could support
a higher power capacity.
It was called the Gramme dynamo, a
continuous-current electrical generator that drove
the push for electrical power.
While arc lighting began showing up on streets
around the world, Thomas Edison realized that arc
lighting was too bright to be used in the home.
This led to his development of the incandescent
lamp.
By capitalizing on the work of many others,
his incandescent lighting systems were soon featured
at popular exhibits such as the Paris Lighting Exhibition
in 1881 and the Crystal Palace in London.
But Edison quickly gained competition, most notably
from George Westinghouse and Nikola Tesla.
This led to what’s now remembered as the
War of Currents,
with Westinghouse and Tesla as proponents
of an alternating, or AC, current against Edison’s
direct, or DC, current.
Edison did his best to discredit AC currents by
trying to convince the public they were dangerous.
He had animals electrocuted by AC currents on
public display, and even recommended electrocution
as a death-penalty alternative to hanging prisoners.
At which he succeeded.
The first person to be executed by electricity was
a convicted murderer named William Kemmler, who
was put to death in the electric chair in 1890.
Despite his other efforts, though, Edison
failed to discredit the push for AC.
Westinghouse won the contract to supply electricity to
the 1893 World’s fair in Chicago, and AC currents have
since become dominant in the electric power industry.
We also have electrical engineering to thank for
many of the electronic devices we use every day.
That brings us to the third field of electrical
engineering: computers.
In their beginning, before World War II,
most computers were part of what was called
“radio engineering”.
Most of the computer’s focus was on radar,
radio, and early television.
Their primary work was in processing the signals
of those devices.
Computers only began to gain a broader audience
after the transistor was developed in 1947.
The point-contact transistor was a semiconductor
device that could amplify or switch electrical signals.
It allowed electrical engineers to replace
vacuum tubes, which were bulky, unstable,
and consumed too much power.
But while the computers could be smaller,
they were still pretty large.
They also needed a separate integrated chip
for each one of their functions.
Then, in 1968, American engineer Marcian Hoff
helped solve these problems.
He conceived of a universal processor that
could be used by all computers.
His work led to the Intel 4004, the world’s
first commercial microprocessor.
Since microprocessors were so tiny, the computers
themselves could be even smaller.
And, that’s how electrical engineers shaped the
world we live in today: with telecommunications,
electric power and lighting, and computers.
The fact is, it takes all three of these fields – none
of which existed until a couple hundred years ago – to
work together, for you to watch me right now.
So today we explored the history of each of these fields, touching on such topics as magnetism, electrical conduction, telegraphy, lighting, and computers.
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check out a playlist of their amazing shows, like Brain Craft, Global Weirding with Katharine Hayhoe, and Hot Mess.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and this
episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.